[Musique]
c'est au stade de l'etivallière à
saint-etienne que s'est déroulé ce
week-end le tournoi andy supporters
l'équipe de la réunion composée de
membres de l'association cécifoot
affrontés pendant deux jours plusieurs
équipes bien plus qu'un tournoi
c'est une démarche importante pour cette
association un moment de partage et de
solidarité
on joue vraiment sur les valeurs les
valeurs humaines sont comme nous arrive
à jouer il arrive à être solide et il
arriva à échanger à communiquer il n'y a
plus de barrières
c'est extraordinaire de vivre cette
expérience là et je pense que nous tous
on le ressent la des rencontres et des
échanges maintenant à l'épanouissement
personnel et à la construction d'une
identité heureuse pour jean j me michael
eyal cet événement leur pas mais aussi
de représenter la réunion
ces pratiques des championnats de france
ça c'était à toulouse
mais là quand vous avez su à
saint-etienne comptant la réunion
l'heure le mieux et ça est fini et ça
comme une fierté pour représenter la
région des monts de gratte si possible
venue à avancer pour dire que me monde
et un complice poncifs que me vois comme
il a des compétences des matériels
je connais le match pour gagner à choper
la boue arrivant final très très content
encore des jeunes qui sont heureux de
s'exprimer et de montrer leur valeur
sûre mais aussi hors du terrain une
approche qui nécessite un investissement
humain logistique et matériel le conseil
général à travers ce ces actions là sont
tous très attachés à ce genre d'action à
ce genre de manifestation et les
accompagnent
l'association cécifoot dans toutes ses
actions travers c'est à dire vraiment un
soutien un soutien qui aider les
associations porteuses de projets et
mettre en avant nos jeunes réunionnais
voilà les objectifs du conseil général
l'équipe de la réunion finira septième
de sa poule
ils reviendront avec une coupe et aussi
des souvenirs plein la tête et le plus
important pour eux c'est le sentiment
d'être considérés comme n'importe quel
sportif
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]